when you won the Oscar pine for Edith
Piaf in Le'Veon Rose which is an amazing
performance but I've heard you an
interviews talking about which seems
like but that was a character you
couldn't shake yeah that was the first
time I had trouble getting rid of her
which I was very ashamed of I have to
say because I thought it's a job I'm an
actress I shouldn't be affected by any
of my roles but I had spent six months
more than six months with her and and I
really entered another dimension I
didn't see my friend and family for this
amount of time because when I would see
them they would find me weird and I
didn't like it and well first of all I
was weird because I was shaved my
eyebrows were shaved and my my hair was
shaved but yeah it took me a while to
just because the thing when you do movie
you spend a lot of time with this person
you fell in love with in a way and then
the last cut is I mean you'll never
share you know your life with this
person anymore so it's sometimes it can
be kind of brutal but but I'm fine now
watching the movie it is unbelievable
that it's not you singing that it you
you lip synched everything that was the
the hardest part of the preparation
actually it's very technical it's super
boring one part was not that boring
because I wanted to take singing lessons
even though I wouldn't sing but I needed
to learn her technique and I wanted to
learn how to position my tongue how to
position myself the breathing and
everything because it had to be
realistic if you don't believe I'm
singing then you can throw the movie in
the garbage I mean it's it's pretty
horrible I got sued I absolutely thought
it was using it in the movie it's so
complete I cried so much about it really
good film thin grandmas hopefully can
you still do the lip-synching I don't
know if we play a bit can you think you
can do it it's in France what we know
because my teeth I mean the teeth I have
in the movie or you know I wore this I
don't know how you call it
don't you all the teeth yes
that's yours Blanche ORS well what we
would call them Wally's up there please
Wally's not Wally's wallings Wally's
Wally's legs Wally's if we play a bit
and you try it if it's terrible we'll
cut those and if it's marvellous we'll
all cap and cheer
[Applause]
all physicality that comes with it and
we've pregnant are you standing or
sitting sitting sitting
oh no I will sit I'm so you kidding
already okay ready sit in of labor I
think we've got what we've got lined up
is towards the end of Jena regret for
you okay no you can't okay roll it roll
it there roll it
[Music]
calimary
[Applause]
Graham Norton here if you'd like to see
even more stuff like that then hit
subscribe or don't it's a free world but
I know what I do in that situation